questions
commitment
um
hi everybody Welcome to the next set of
talks so next we're going to have
quickly we're going to talk about
spectral Independence so take care
yeah we do
hi everyone uh can everyone hear me okay
yeah all right cool uh so yeah so I'll
be talking about the spectral
Independence which I guess you can think
of it as like a different like a more
probabilistic or purely statistical
formulation of some of the ideas we saw
earlier this week on particular High
dimensional expanders
um right so I guess I I personally come
from this area I work in this area
called counting and sampling and really
the just to give a little motivation the
the main problem that we're interested
in is the following so we have a
distribution
given some distribution
and typically it's just for convenience
say on the Boolean Cube
but you know we can think of say any
product space or whatever we want and
our goal is to the goal is to draw
samples from you
so this is an exponential art domain but
I want to do it efficiently it's like a
polynomial time
and some typical examples that we'll be
interested in this talkers
or it's a classically studied
combinatorial models so for instance say
uniform distribution
over stuff like matchings
the independent sets
colorings
trees
and so on
and so and in particular I'll be
interested in settings where at least
even the underlying support of the
distribution has no appearance like
algebraic or algebraic structure or
symmetries to it okay
any any states another just one more
class of examples that is often studied
in like say statistical physics settings
or machine learning settings and this is
really like a weighted distribution so
here
so here's one more example
so
I have a matrix a
and I'm gonna wait each configuration so
throughout I write Sigma for a plus
minus one vector and dimensional we wait
each configuration is proportional to
exponential
quadratic form
foreign
example of an easing model it's a very
non-uniform distribution you should
think of this Matrix a here as being
like the adjacency Matrix like a
weighted adjacency Matrix of some graph
if like say the entry you know aij is uh
maybe one motivation for this would be
something like you're like modeling a
social network or something if the AI
jth entry is positive then maybe person
I and person J are like friends if it's
negative then maybe they're enemies and
the plus minus one is just like a like a
you know how they vote for instance so
these are just some like concrete
example to keep in mind and again let me
emphasize there's like no I'm not
there's not going to be like any like
algebraic structure or symmetry to this
so the classical approach that's used in
practice and in theory is that you may
that you probably know about is to run
Markov chains
and let me just for the rest of this
talk is focused on a very simple class
and very classically studied uh Markov
chain called lava Dynamics
foreign
just given by the following two-step
process so say I'm starting
at some configuration Sigma
okay
so in each step I'm going to first pick
a random coordinate I say uniformly at
random
then I'm going to resample
only the ith coordinates condition on
everybody else
we need to be a little bit more concrete
just in the case of the Boolean Cube so
for instance I will toss a biased coin
or I flip
uh the ith coordinate with across this
probability
hear this xori is just on Flipping that
coordinate so with with this probability
flip
how do I stay
okay
um so a couple notes so for instance
typically I do not even know the
normalizing constant to this
distribution but I can actually run this
Dynamics because I can compute the ratio
because the normalizing constants cancel
out so this algorithm is actually
implementable okay
I'm just going to keep running this
two-step process over and over again
and second thing is that when you know
is that
and this is not hard to check is that if
I run this Dynamics to Infinity
then the distribution of the end state
of my markup chain is going to be
exactly the distribution I want okay so
more formally
so you can under a very like mild
assumptions like say on connectivity of
the distribution you can prove that
so under
mild assumptions
prove that for every
starting State Sigma
if I start from that state and I evolve
the markup chain for T steps and I
compare it with my the distribution I
care about it's like polar variation
distance it's going to go to zero
there's t
it goes today
but of course for algorithmic purposes
we really want this convergence to be
fast like in polynomial number of steps
it's going to get to like say epsilon
it's going to get Epsilon close
to stationary
okay
so we want what we really want now we
really want
they want
fasting
uh say for T less than polynomial
and say like log one of Epsilon
TV
let's look at most
excellent that's kind of what we want
okay
so
how do we typically approach this so
this is through this is like this very
beautiful observation that um
for many years ago that you know this
mixing time is controlled by functional
inequalities okay such as spectral gaps
such as log so we'll have inequality so
let me just State those now
and these are intimately related to many
of the functional inequalities that
we've seen earlier this week
let me Define
State them is our goal will be to
develop new tools
to establish these functional
inequalities in these types of settings
so to Define I need to First Define
quadratic form so they call the
dirichlet form
so
sorry I guess I should have said P here
is just the transition probability
Matrix of the markup chain
so I'm going to find this quadratic form
e sub p
it'll consume two functions on entire
domain and it's just given by the
following quadratic form
so I look at the Matrix I minus P if you
think of this as like a laplacian I'm
going to hit it with a function G take
an inner product with f and the inner
product is a weighted one with respect
to the stationary distribution
okay
so if you want to see it so it just to
give you an example so for Global
Dynamics
power dynamics
for concreness this looks like my sum
overall configuration Sigma
mu Sigma and now I look at the
transitions from Sigma
times
basically the local variation of these
functions
across that transition
sorry is this okay it's a sledgeable
hopefully
um and I guess especially to some of you
who have come from sort of analysis
Boolean functions this kind of quantity
should look very familiar okay so I
guess here I've included I guess a very
short dictionary so translating between
some of the concepts that are typically
used in Markov chains and typically
those typically used in analysis
building functions
so here you can think of the dirichlet
form as if I take G to be equal to f
and I'd look at say the MU being the
uniform measure of the Boolean Cube then
this then this quantity is exactly the
average influence of that function that
we saw earlier this week
and there's a translation between the
noise operator and the globar Dynamics
and I guess I'll I'll say I'll say in a
bit what exactly is there uh log sublip
will be equivalent in a very precise
sense to hyper contractivity
okay so we have the dirichlet form
and I need to tell you what are these
functional inequalities that I'm going
to use to control mixing
foreign
qualities we want
so typically we we start with sort of
the ease around which is uh one is
called a punk array inequality
or the spectral Gap
which just says that we're all functions
f
but I have the following inequality the
variance respective stationary
distribution U the global variance is
upper bounded by the local variance
up to a factor of Lambda
and it's well known that this implies if
you have such an inequality this implies
mixing
time
order one over Lambda
Times log of 1 over the minimum
stationary probability
plus log
first
typically in say the Boolean Cube you'll
expect the spectral Gap to be like 1
over n
the minimum stationary probability will
typically be exponentially small in N so
this would be like an N squared upper
bound on the mixing time
roughness we can get much better so
you can also ask for say the amount say
entropy inequalities which give a much
sharper control in the mixing time so
the modified Luxo beloved inequality
which is in some sense more appropriate
for discrete settings but
depends on the application of course so
for all non-negative okay let's just say
overall functions f
I have appalling inequality the global
entropy
squared
let's say non-negative
Global entropy of f is upper bounded by
the seriously form now I put F and I put
log F here
or if I change this to standard
locks level of inequality
I really
a very similar look in quantity
foreign
by something slightly strange is the
square root of the function f but the
point is that if you have this stronger
control on these two
um this time it's stronger inequalities
then this implies
it's going to be legible from okay
doesn't imply much better mixing so in
particular
mixing
in time
order one over either of these constants
except now I have log log
okay so I can if I can get like say a
one over n upper lower bound on these
constants then I'll get n log n next
thing which is typically optimal
stainless steel
I say again
sorry okay yeah maybe I should Define
entropy
foreign
okay
okay so our goal is to establish such uh
functional influence
so essentially these come from
what this allow you to do is control so
you depends on like how you measure
convergence right so we typically
measure in terms of polar variation but
collaboration is upper bound if I say
relative entropy you want to measure
things in relative entropy and these two
quantities exactly control the the rate
of convergence
other questions
I guess it's true for the modifying Lots
over there
yeah I mean I guess I'd say that this is
like a standard it's like stronger than
modified there's a slight discrepancy in
the discrete setting but
it's just I guess so this is connection
between mixing and sort of functional
inequalities
let's say
uh what is this thing called spectral
dependence which is how we're going to
try to prove such inequalities
so remember we're really working in a
setting where there's no Independence
between coordinates so classical
strategies like pencilization or just
kind of fail
we're going to sort of approach it by
in some sense quantifying like how far
your distribution is from truly
independent right
I guess this should be uh foreign
talked about yesterday on like
approximate product spaces but it'll be
slightly different in the definition
okay so now I want to Define spectrum
dependence I wrote the same thing twice
okay
let me explain that space
okay so in order to find what is
spectral Independence let me Define
something called
so I typically call it an influence
Matrix but since influence is such an
overloaded term I'm going to call it
conditional influence okay
just to distinguish it from
you said analysis functions
so so I have a big distribution but I'm
going to define a very small Matrix
so for all coordinates I and J
I'm going to find the conditional
influence
it's just PSI
it's just the
difference of two marginal probabilities
where condition none
the the presence or absence of the index
probably by sample
a random configuration Sigma what is the
probability that Sigma Maps straight
plus one condition on knowing that I is
mapped to plus one
now minus the same thing
I've conditioned
typing mapped to mice
so you can kind of think of this as also
like an influence or a conditional
influence because you're asking for how
much does knowing the value for I
influence the marginal probability
anything like unbiased right so I had
some some arbitrary distribution I can
Define correlations in this way
so now okay so I have this Matrix I can
ask about eigenvalues and stuff so I'm
going to say
say mu
is Ada sexually independent
if the largest eigenvalue
we can do this for I and J this gives me
an N by n Matrix so it's a small Matrix
the large eigenvalue is upper bounded
by one plus eight
it's the one that's just for technical
reasons it's just coming from the fact
that with I equals straight and this
difference is 1.
okay so a few comments first this Matrix
is in general asymmetric and can have
negative and positive entries so it's
not even clear that it has real
eigenvalues so what does this even mean
so the way they see this we see that it
always has realizing now it's just by
relating it to the covariance Matrix so
the distribution which is something
perhaps more familiar
so an equivalent way
equivalent formulation
is to say that if I look at the
covariance Matrix
so I have plus minus one vectors I can
talk about the covariance
this is upper bounded in the PSD order
by 1 plus Theta times
an appropriate diagonal matrix so I put
a variance of each chord
okay
so using this you can also then show
that the influence metric has realizing
lines so these are like two ways to
think about what spectral Independence
means just stop controlling all the
pairwise correlations in the
distribution
let's see some examples so in a moment
I'll tell you how this is related to for
instance the Notions of high dimensional
expansion that we saw earlier this week
but I just want to like first do some
examples and state some like what you
can get out of this this definition
foreign
tell me what the special independence of
a product measure is
true
another diagonal but you know the one
accounts for diagonal so it's different
so
others
that's also kind of explains the name
let's do the Other Extreme okay so now
suppose I look at
following mixture take one half
probability everybody all wants
one half probability
or minus one okay so what's the special
independence of this
exactly right it's all once Matrix so
the max eigenvalue is n
and minus one especially
so
right because if I know the value of one
coordinate that determines everybody
else
right so in this case the includes
Matrix is all once
this implies n minus one specifically
we see that there's a two experience
right so this is a distribution with
disconnected support I expect Robert
Dynamics is definitely not going to mix
and you can kind of detect that through
how bad how large the Spectrum appears
is
let's see one last example which is
so let's say one more example so so
let's let
U the uniform
over
say spending trees
so
so classical results called The Matrix
tree theorem which you might have heard
of in the context like spectrography and
such is that this distribution is
negatively correlated
because you can write this distribution
using like the permanence speaking
this means that
if I
so for all
pairs of edges in my graph
if I sample a random spanning tree from
the distribution the probability of that
f
is in the tree condition on knowings in
the tree
is that most
so knowing so having another Edge in the
tree is only going to decrease my
chances
okay so what does this say about the
influence Matrix for the uniform
distribution or spanning tree
exactly so all non all the off diagram
entries
okay so what does that say about
spectral Independence so so first so if
I have if I'm looking at the max login
value I can always upper bound it
by say the infinity Norm
Matrix
this is just I look at
the worst case choice of edge e and
total influence of that edge on
everybody else
let's say conditional
influence okay
so now I can use the fact that you know
all the off diagonal entries are
non-positive they're all the same signs
so I'm just summing up a bunch of
probabilities and I can use linearly of
expectation so this is really
equal to the maximum of the choice of
edge e of now it's really just instead
of sum of absolute values it's just
absolute value of the sum
let's use sometimes just for shorthand
I'll use ebar to note that the E is not
in my sample
tree
okay so this is just so this is exactly
just
by sample a random expanding tree
condition on having that e what is the
expected size of that tree
well clearly if I know that gee I've
contracted that edge and I have a graph
of with n minus 1 minus vertices all
expanding trees at such graph have mis2
edges right and similarly for this one
so this is just
two
what I can deduce a constant up around a
very nice constant upper bound on a
spectral Independence of the
distribution using very classical tools
um
right yeah but I guess you'll have you
have a little ones I mean you can do
better than this using something called
lock on cavity but I'll get that later
okay so this is just using some very uh
negative correlations that are very
heavily studied topic
how do you control these uh constants uh
yeah so I'll get there so I just want to
First say some examples so now I'll now
say like how if you have special
Independence what implications it has
for these mixes that's why this message
just first
um so any questions about like the
definition I mean if you take nothing
away just that's this
one so this is always holds right so the
eigenvalues are always upper bounded by
matrix Norms induced by Vector norms
that's always true
uh sorry so I guess I guess it is just
this one so yeah so maybe
opportunity Norms Matrix is just
okay
so it's a nature sound induced by
Infinity War
right because I'm using the fact that
all these awesome monitories are the
same time they're all non-positive
yeah I'm crucial using in fact I know
negative correlation for this
distribution it's not I can't do this
thank you
how many states in terms
sorry is there a question
all right it's the first theorem this is
really just like a translation of some
of these results in the area of high
dimensional expanders so this is really
due to
love it now
that says the following so if
the first of course I cannot reduce
anything useful if I only impose this on
the description itself I need like a
multi-scale condition right I cannot
control just based off the paralyzed
correlations alone
so if new
and all
conditionals
so when I say conditional I just mean I
pick a subset of coordinates and I you
know put plus minus ones there and then
I induce a conditional measure on
everybody else yeah so for all
exponentially many of these conditional
measures
so if all of them are
data spectrally independent
then
you say
is lower bounded by
and the one percent
yeah it goes into the exponent s
of the bound
but you know if Ada is constant which is
what we're shooting for that's like the
gold standard in some sense then this is
polynomial mixing
this is only a cycle cap so this is
nothing about log sub Library
but actually okay so we want more of
course okay so you know for most like
practical applications of course like
end of the five mixing is also kind of
not acceptable
um so we want to do more so but we need
to add some assumptions so at least for
a lot of the applications that uh it's
uh that like say some school physicists
are interested in like release like okay
I guess I erase it but these like graph
problems like independent sets or
colorings they have an additional
structure to them
that's uh
and that's why we're gonna add as an
additional function
so the second theorem
suppose I impose the same the same
information
that's the first condition
second condition is just that the
distribution emits like an additional
nice uh factorization property in the
following sense
new
satisfies
with something called like say
global
Markov property
so let's say
something it's also called
conditional Independence
with respect to
be found so I'll explain what exactly
this means
yeah translated now so what does this
mean so I have a so imagine I have a
distribution over plus minus on
assignments to vertices of a graph
and I just wanted to satisfy the
following property if I
condition on the values of the
assignments to vertices in a separator
then in the resulting conditional
distribution the distribution of this
configuration here and the distribution
of the configuration here are completely
independent of each other after I have
conditioned on this right so this is
kind of like if I have I have a graph
and then you know where I have like say
two disk to destroying graphs or not
connected to each other and the
distribution of independent sets is just
the product of the description of
independent sets for the each piece
that's just like nice uh sort of
factorization property and about the
greenness is just sorry not bounded
founded degree
the boundary graph assumptions just so
that uh
apps and Spar cities but it's like it's
not it's another way to quantify the
uh
relations are too strong
and the third is something
which
also has come up previously is just that
um
marginals
I just mean like the probability of a
given coordinate is sine plus minus one
those are all like constants they're not
like going to zero
so this is some technical assumption
that's perhaps if you remember from like
say the analysis of P by SQ this is
necessary for getting something like a
log sublet
surprise
that you know say
hope it's okay if I just say Lambda row
app
so these are the all these constants
here
and one Iran is is the best thing you
hope for and this gives you n log n
mixing for collaborative
questions
so typically I'll assume the graph is
bounded degree and and in that sense so
I'll have this and this will also
made it yeah okay so
and I guess there's a lot of other
interesting Works Say by Nema and also
by Ronin Aldan and Juan Citron which
sort of if you impose different set of
assumptions you know maybe not that it
comes from a graph or you can even relax
this marginal balance assumption you can
still deduce maybe not necessarily
standard lock so blood but modified
locks over list and it's all very
interesting it works but unfortunately I
won't have time to talk about this
the OCCC becomes
it's always
right because I need this thing for all
conditions
the question oh the question was just
that does it become easier if I assume
pairwise Independence for the
distribution but you know I need this
for all conditionals as well
if I assume pairwise Independence maybe
I can improve by a constant here but I
want it for like many different like
sort of levels so to speak I understand
the question correctly
you have this almost always independence
of those conditioning right so I want
for all conditioning I still have like
abound on this like okay
how do we should expand the most
okay so so I'll say more precisely uh
so I guess okay in like 10 minutes I'll
say like how like this is related to the
notional height motion expansion it was
really it came from there like that's
how it came across but like there is a
there is a reason why like we sort of
stated this way but okay
also like how do you show that they have
like a small parameters
or something so how do you show that
like
uh which one the marginals how do I show
that it is small for uh yeah that's not
easy so yeah so that will be the subject
of I guess
um
the rest so the end of this talk and
also the next so I'll show you some
techniques that we've developed to found
this thing yeah it's not easy
but those influence matrices they were
like I mean the spectral Independence
definition is
new right but like the people studied
this Matrix with like stronger bounds on
it before
uh like but like bounds and enough to
give you like path coupling
this influence Matrix okay if you're
talking about if you're are you talking
about
yeah yeah so the Russian is okay I guess
we can take this question offline but um
but roughly speaking to operation is uh
it's actually a slightly different
nature so you somehow take entry-wise
maximum over all possible conditionings
for Gentry and the original have one
Matrix here have exponentially many
yeah maybe it's a bit technical you can
pick it up but okay I'll say one more
thing if you have that condition that
the version this will apply this
condition but this is weird
exactly
okay so I guess uh right so
I guess now I can erase this function of
all this stuff since really we're just
going to focus on establishing this okay
I guess like my goal in this talk isn't
necessarily to like prove like all the
theorems or anything but it's just to
show some examples and carry some
techniques on how you verify this kind
of
foreign
[Music]
through those results I also I also want
to highlight there's a very nice other
result in terms of getting concentration
directly from spectral dependence
nutrition
I mean of course you can always go from
say a modified log so we'll have
inequality to concentration but there's
a more direct way that sort of gets
better much better parameters at least
for linear functions
linear
oops
and even Matrix value is fine and that's
like really
this is due to Hoffman
because it's here somewhere okay anyways
um yeah I just want to highlight this is
yellow Infinity
yeah so it's all unfinity using slightly
stronger but okay
yeah that's why this is I think it's a
cool result
um okay so this implies nice things how
do we verify this so this is a high
level overview there are sort of similar
classes of techniques that we know how
to do
yeah
that we know how to use to get verified
this property so first let's just say
it's based off of
various Notions of coupling and I'll
actually try this if I have time I'll
try to sketch one of these a very cute
example the second is based off of
something called geometry polynomials
so you encode your distribution
multivariable and you study its analytic
properties and use that to deduce
probabilistic statements about your
distribution meal that's basically the
subject of the second talk
um there's techniques based off this
thing called decay of correlations
it's like a classical structural
property of the distribution that it's
often studied in statistical physics but
well I won't have time to get to that
and I guess final one of course
after I tell you the connection to high
dimensional expanders
is a trickle down here
and I guess okay so I pulled you so I'm
going to tell you maybe build a coupling
today geometry polynomials in the next
talk
and I guess tomorrow
I'll try to say some things about like
proof of these things okay but for today
it's just how do you verify this
condition
yes
it's fine too it's okay if I just
erasing this
okay so I just want to say very briefly
the connection with high dimensions
okay so what's the connection so of
course I need to build a central
conflicts on my distribution okay and
this is something that was already
helpfully done for me essentially for me
by Max and Erie but I'm just going to
just remind everyone what the
construction is so is there a mu is on
in the end
like construct a weighted synthesial
complex so
let's call that X mu
vertices
correspond to pairs of coordinates
coordinate and assignment pair
is important
as an assignment
and then the facets the maximal faces
they correspond to
it sets of the following form of I
signify
foreign
so I guess pectorally you can imagine
like I have like all these coordinates
there's only two elements in here but
um you just pick one from each
and view that as I said
and of course I'm gonna wait it by the
corresponding stationary bedroom all
right so I guess the reason I'm also
doing this is because kind of
a lot of the previous stocks on high
dimensional expanders they did
everything sort of in the in the case
where the complex is like super regular
everything is uniform and I just thought
it might be helpful to also state things
when it's not uniform
is everything so it makes sense
so this is a simple complex
um
okay so now what is high dimensional
expansion
so I'm going to use sort of the
local spectral
standard definition
so what is local
full expansion
foreign
blocks so I'm walking on
a coordinate assignment pair going to a
pair of according to Simon pairs that
are coming back down
so the more the more general definition
is of these little random blocks in the
non-uniform setting is defined so it's
going to call it q u
so it's gonna
starting from
a coordinate assignment pair is
and I'll walk to another coordinate JT
okay
that's going to be exactly equal to of a
sub normalization
the probability
of a sample Sigma
a new Sigma okay
so of course if your thing is super
irregular then you know this is just
uniform right it's just actually just a
regular random watch if your thing is
not uniform then you weigh things
correctly by the marginals of the
elements or the coordinate assignment
pairs
an expansion is just saying that this
look random block has a specular Gap so
if I look at the second eigenvalue of
this random mark this is that North
State
foreign
dependence
I guess first I'll say
you can improve that you know the
trickle down theorem also works in this
in this setting
just a quick question yeah so this is
like the local market level
yeah sorry yeah it's a level zero then
to get the ones at different links then
you just look at the conditional so
that's huge
okay so now let me State the sort of
open times trickle down theorem and sort
of the highest level of generality
Central conflicts
this is the following so if Q Nu
is connected
and say for all
coordinate assignment pairs
I have a spectral Gap or look right now
what after I have condition on
when I getting the assignments
then I can say something
give you itself where I no longer have
this condition
and then let me just say this is like an
observation okay so now this is really
the connection between sexual
Independence
and these local random works so we
actually have an identity so if I look
at the second eigenvalue of this random
walk
this is equal to there's there's no this
is it identity this is equal to one over
n minus one times
Matrix
it kind of you it kind of makes sense
because influence Matrix has all these
conditional marginal probabilities and
the one over n minus one this comes from
the scaling
foreign
obtain spectral Independence and you
might rightly wonder
okay I've had this equivalence you know
why the heck would I ever might I Define
spectral dependence to begin with
I guess
um
I guess there are a few reasons the
original motivation for defining this
notion was to capture the following
phenomena so if you notice
in this in trickle down
the expansion degrades as you go down
the conflicts whereas you sort of have
fewer conditions
but in most sampling applications
um what you actually observe is that
actually improves as you go down the
complex
and that's where you see like if I have
this as a constant but this is this is
saying bounded but n is going to
Infinity the expansion is actually
improving as I go down the concept so
this special Independence was sort of
designed to capture that phenomenon okay
there's no degradation
I guess there are also like a couple
like it's just I guess maybe for me like
some nice aspects of spectral dependence
so for instance you can prove
very simple calculation that for
instance if I look at the influence
Matrix
two measures and take their product this
has a nice block form
so in particular analyzing product
measures it's very easy I mean easier it
makes things convenient for calculations
and I guess since I'm not so good at you
know topology I think it's for me it's
easier to unders to understand like
influences correlations covariances
something a bit more familiar more
probabilistic
but of course like and I guess one more
thing is also like once you have a
London Max it becomes very natural to
found things using Matrix norms
very naturally
of course everything's equivalent you
could do everything in this language
any questions about the connection
uh Lord do I have how much more time do
I have
okay
we'll try to sketch just one I think a
very cute example of how like you can
use coupling to establish special
effects
foreign
so here's an example
coupling
so the the example I'm going to work
with is the phone so I have a graph G
say its maximum degree
is bound at maximum degree
and let mu is uniform
or matchings
I mean all matches not just perfect
matching I mean all magic so I include
the MPS okay
okay so the claim or the way I want to
prove
a new
is a Delta plus one
actually independent
and this in particular implies that
Global Dynamics
so so first a couple remarks like
historical remarks so first this uh this
model over studied
not maybe not first studied but the
first like I guess maybe major result on
this was like Jeremy Sinclair
approved polynomial mixing
or slightly different Dynamics not
exactly Dynamics but uh for any
even the maximum can be unbounded but uh
just for Simplicity I'm working in the
bounded degree setting
and I guess this is also an illustration
of like special Independence in the
sense that I don't know of like a
coupling proof of this that is markup
chain makes its way
okay
okay so now I'm gonna do this
I mean a coupling like classical sense
so so I guess here's the here's the
lemon that we're going to use
I guess first thing to know it's like
you know if I condition on edge being in
or out then I just get the uniform
distribution we're matching itself like
a subgraph okay so just without
entrepreneuriality I can and for
convenience I can just work with just
really just the original ref G itself
and the original distribution
okay so here's a limit so for all I've
received in the graph
and also for all couplings
gamma
oh say distribution new condition on
e being in the matching
The View where I condition on E being
not in the matching
you have that the total influence this
Edge e
bounded by
the expectation where if I sample two
matchings
on the coupling
and look at the size of the symmetric
difference
or if I if I think of them as like
vectors this is like Hamming distance
between us
basically okay if I have this so I can
also say this institute
together
and the way we're going to prove this
proposition is just to like construct
this coupling integer
so let me first uh prove this
all we need to do is just open up
the definition of the influence okay so
if I look at say one particular
influence so I look at the probability
that f is in the matching condition on E
okay so I like fixed some f here
so this is exactly equal to if I look at
really you can think of it as I look at
the total variation distance between
like a distribution mu condition on E
and I look at the marginal on F
and I do the same thing where enough
condition on
so I'm really just comparing the
flavoration distance between two
conditional distributions well variation
distance admits by Duality like a
coupling formulation I look at
best possible coupling such that you
know I get the the
Edge aft have the same status okay so in
particular if I sum all these
uh
all these edges f
is that most if I pull the infamous
couplings out
uh
efficient of
now I can use linear expectation I sum
overall edges f this indicator
thank you
that's exactly this this thing is
exactly the
symmetric difference between the two
matchings
this interpret influences of polar
variation distance
sir
I can very quickly sketch then the
coupling that you can construct
iteratively for this application
okay
I'll replace this one
I think
so I just imagine yes it's easier to use
two different colors
so
just imagine I have two copies of my
graph
and in one of them I'm assuming the
matching
contains Edge e
and then the other one I'm assuming
doesn't contain the HD
and I want to sample a matching for the
rest of the graph and I want it so that
these two matchings are agree on
everybody else as much as possible
so how can I do this
so this is The Edge key
so now this edgy has some other edges
coming out of it
I'm going to start sampling these edges
so here's a question for you guys
um so
okay let's just look at this vertex here
vertex uh
so in any coupling any coupling at all
how much can the disagreement between
these two matches propagate to this
neighborhood
does the question make sense
right so
so remember I want these two matchings
to have the same work very as close as
possible the same set of edges
right so I'm going to sample the edges
these neighboring edges
and I want to ensure that you know
there's a most like like minimized
number of disagreements let's just say
for this neighborhood okay so what is an
upper bound on the maximum possible
number of disagreements just for the
neighboring edges
it's one
because of the matching constraint if
any one of these guys so first off in
this in this matching all these guys
have to be red right because
and so it's really just the question of
you know
which edge here is matched right if I
pick one of them to be matching it also
kills everybody else and so I can only
have at most one disagreement so the
disagreement can only propagate almost
once to a neighboring Edge
okay so now I just need to
feature so one
so I'm just starting from one Edge right
and I can propagate the agreement to
maybe at most
like one other Edge
then everybody else have to be out
by the matching constraint
s
so I can also do that one but I'm just
going to start from One Direction and
then couple the rest of the graph let's
do this build is coupling iterative
why is that the screaming can only
propagate most ones
so I've seen a bounds so it's just
everything's just controlled by the
probability that this green Edge happens
versus it stays red in which case all
these neighbors have coupled perfectly
and you can upper bound that probability
by the really the claim that you have
the proof which I won't have time for is
I guess maybe door will be mad at me
um it's just um
same as that's you know the probability
let's say in this in this in this
picture here probably that this Edge U
has a matched
condition
s
at most accessories
this is not hard to prove but uh maybe
after that
so for the middle of the time but we
have a time for one or two quick
questions so any question for quickly
so let's think quickly again
and we'll come back in 30 minutes